how
do we
adapt the human body to stress of this
kind
for periods of multiple years
what what lessons do you draw from that
study and other experiments in space
that
give you an indication of how we can
survive for multiple years
i think we know that the radiation is is
one of the biggest risk factors and this
has been well described by nasa and many
other astronauts and researchers and so
there we don't have to just
measure the radiation or just look at
dna being damaged we can actually
actively repair it this happens
naturally in all of our cells there's a
little enzyme little protein
really many machines that go around and
scan dna for nicks and breaks and repair
it we could improve them we could add
more of them or you can even
activate them before you go into space
so we have a one set of cells in my lab
where you but you activate them before
we irradiate them to actually prepare
them for the dose of radiation and now
that is what's called epigenetic
crispr therapies where you can actually
instead of adding or taking away a gene
or modifying a cell you just change kind
of how it's packaged like i was just
describing the dna
the genes are still there we're just
changing how they get used and so you
can actually preemptively activate dna
repair genes and we've done this for
cells we haven't done this yet for
astronauts but we've done it for cells
and a similar idea to this is being used
to treat sickle cell disease and beta
thalassemias you actually you can
reactivate a gene that was dormant in
his way as a therapy so should we make
human genes resilient to harsh
conditions or should we get good at
repairing them
i want to i want to get good at right
okay start to interrupt i think every
time i ask this question you have taught
me
that there's always a third option
i know uh you know for for copy it's
good to just have one big statement but
uh but you want to do both a good or a
third option i would want to you know do
electromagnetic shielding i would want
to do a fourth option of you know maybe
some other uh kind of physical defenses
outside of the human body yeah so we're
taking the same passion to keep
astronauts safe that's outside them and
just putting it in their cells is what i
propose now it's a bit radical today
because
uh you know we're just starting this in
clinical trials to treat you know
diseases on earth so it's not ready i
think to do an astronauts but in the
book i proposed by about the year 2040
that's when we'd reach this next phase
where i think we'll have known enough
about the clinical response we'll have
the technology ironed out
that's about when it's time i think to
try it
so
what are the some interesting early
milestones
so you said uh 2040
what do we have to look forward to in
the next 10 20 years according to your
book according to your thoughts a lot of
really exciting developments where
if you
really want to activate genes like i was
just describing or or repair a specific
disease gene you can actually crispr it
out modify it this has been already
published and well documented but as
alluding to
more and more we'll see people that you
just want to temporarily change your
genes functions and change their
activity so the best example this is for
beta thalassemia we all have hemoglobin
in our blood that carries oxygen around
and when you're an adult it's a
different version it's a different gene
you have one gene when you're a fetus
called fetus fetal hemoglobin when
you're adult you have a different gene
but they both are making a protein that
carries oxygen when you after you're
born the fetal hemoglobin gene gets just
turned off just it goes away and you
replace it with adult hemoglobin but if
your gene for hemoglobin is bad as an
adult
with one of the therapies well let's
turn back on the gene that you had when
you were a fetus and it's actually
already led to cures for sickle cell and
beta thalassaemia in this past year
so it's this extraordinary idea of like
well you already have some of the
genetic solutions in your body why don't
we just reactivate them and see if you
can live and indeed you can so i think
we'll see more of that that's for severe
disease but eventually you could see it
for more
uh i think work-related purposes like if
you're working in a dangerous mine or in
a radio a high radiation environment you
could you could basically start to prime
it for you know work safety basically we
need to genetically protect you now it
would have to be shown that that genetic
option is safe reliable
you know that it's better
at least as good or if not better than
other shielding methods but i think
we'll start to see that more in the next
10 20 years and eventually as i describe
in the book you can get to recreational
genetics you could say well i want to
turn some genes on just for this weekend
because i'm going to a high altitude so
i'd like to prepare for that and so
instead of having to take weeks and
weeks for acclimation
you could just do some quick epigenetic
therapies and have a good time in the
mountains and then come back and turn
them back off so this is stuff to do on
earth yeah across thousands of humans
and then you start getting good data
about what the effects in the human body
are
how do we make humans survive
across the entire lifetime for let's say
several decades in space
if it's just in space it'll be hard
because you'll you'll need basically
some gravity at some point i think you'd
need orbital platforms that give you at
least some partial gravity if not 1g
if you're on mars it's actually
you know even though the gravity is 38
of earth's just having that gravity
would be enough and if you could get
under the surface into some of the lava
tubes where you have some protection
above you uh from the radiation i think
that would be you probably could survive
quite well there so i think it's the
just in space part that's hard you need
some gravity you need some additional
protection from the radiation can you uh
linger on the lava tubes on mars what
are the lava tubes
yes so they are a bit like what they
sound like there were large masses of
lava at one point on the planet pushing
really quickly through the environment
and they created these
these basically these small caverns
which you could go in in theory and
build a small habitat and then puff it
up kind of like blowing up a balloon
and have a protective habitat basically
it's a little bit underground so one of
the next helicopter missions being
planned at the jet propulsion lab is to
see if you can get a helicopter to go
into the lava tube
and which is just like as it sounds kind
of like take out a big worm that has
burrowed into the landscape and leave
out the hollow
column that's left and that's what your
tubes look like so one of the future
helicopters might even go explore one of
them is a mission being planned right
now so they're accessible without a
significant amount of drilling yeah
that's the other advantage yeah you can
get to them because some of them are
exposed you could do a little bit of
drilling and then see essentially this
entire thing texture a little bit from
the radiation right because you have
some soil above you basically which
would be a regal lift which would be
nice what about source of
food uh what's a good so that's part of
biology how you power this whole thing
what about source of food across decades
in space we have space plants have been
grown in flight and you can get some
nutrients but right now it is very
reliant on
all the up mass being sent up all the
you know freeze-dried fruit the thing
gets rehydrated
which doesn't taste awful but is is not
uh
it's not self-reliant right so i think
those would have to be small bioreactors
that have to be a lot of it work on
fermentation a lot of work on you know
potentially prototrophic organisms the
organs that can make all of the 20 amino
acids that you would need to eat i'd
describe a little bit in the book what
if we did a prototrophic human where you
could have like right now we need to we
need to get some of our amino acids
because we can't make them all which i
think is kind of sad
so what if we could make all of our own
amino acids or all of our own vitamins
i also you know i think that's one case
where another adaptation could be to
activate the vitamin c gene like right
right now you'd have to have limes or
some other source of vitamin c in space
but we actually carry the gene inside of
our genome to make vitamin c look at
dogs and cats for example they have
these kind of wet noses
you don't see them going out and getting
margaritas
the dogs can drink beer and get drunk
they don't need vitamin c they have no
risk of scurvy because they can make the
vitamin c all by themselves so can other
wet-nosed primates called strep-cerinis
but we are drynose primates and we lost
this ability sometimes 10 or 20 million
years ago we no longer make our own
vitamin c but the gene for it is called
gulo is still in our dna it's what's
called a pseudogene it's just broken
down
it's like having a like in our genome we
have these functional genes like nice
bmw a nice car that works well but we
also have this like wrecking this like
junkyard of cold cars old genes old
functions in our dna that we could bring
back and so vitamin c is one of them
that would be very easy to do
so then you could activate the gene
repair it basically repair so we can
make our own vitamin c
now we'd have to do it again carefully
because what if what if we lost vitamin
c the production of vitamin c as a
species what if it was a good reason
that we lost it maybe it was helping in
some other way that we can't see now but
you'd start slowly do it in cells then
do it you know potentially in animal
models and primary other primates and
the triton humans but that's something
else i'd like to see so we wouldn't have
to make as much food in orbit you could
actually start to make as much of your
own food in your own cells so the input
to the system in terms of energy could
be much more restricted it doesn't have
to have the diversity we currently need
as humans but i don't want to be a robot
humans love i as i do texture i i
realized that made me sound like i
wasn't human but humans uh love food and
flavors and textures and smells all that
all that is actually attenuated in
flight so it's you'd want to
not forget our humanity and so this this
you know love of of all the benefits and
wonder of food and cooking and smells
well speak for yourself because for me i
eat the same thing every single day and
i um
i find beauty in everything and some
beauty is more easily accessible outside
of earth and food is not one of those
things i think what about insects
the people bring that up basically food
that has sex with itself and multiplies
so cockroaches and so on they're a
source of a lot of
um
protein and a lot of the amino acids
and bed bugs there's a guy at the
american museum in natural history in
new york he loves bed bugs lou sorkin
and he has a monthly meeting where he
talks about how which insects would be
the best for eating and one one month he
gave a whole talk about bed bugs that
they're pretty gross but in terms of the
value of what you can get for protein
they're really good so
they're they're a good candidate i think
you'd have if you could deep fry them if
you deep fry anything you can pretty
much eat it so maybe you need a fryer up
in space but they're a candidate